my buddy zack he's like 100
positive like oh he was killed he was
killed there's no way he wasn't he was
killed
but look unlike epstein
you know i know you the epstein he was
definitely murdered
unlike epstein like this part like the
the mcafee man that's that's bizarre
this guy is literally saying look these
people are out to get me
right they're coming for me they've sent
me messages i'm
i'm not gonna kill myself i'm not
suicidal i'm
perfectly you know i'm perfectly sane
i'm not depressed i mean he's saying all
these tweets he's sending out tweets
he's sending out messages
and then as soon as you find out okay
he's going to be extradited to the
united states within hours he's found
hung in
in his uh cell so what's your take on it
what do you think happened
well i mean uh first of all do you think
he killed himself or do you think what
do you think
you know i hate to say that i hate to
say oh he didn't because i don't know
you don't know exactly no this is all
special right right but i mean i hate to
be
i hate those guys that rush to judgment
and it's like you know it reminds me of
um
yeah but that's what podcasts are about
they're about being monday morning
quarterbacks i know but i hate that
they're about they're about stealing in
your ideas slinging your opinion you
know what bothers me
it when i grow up whatever you say is a
fact matt
it's not a fact but look look you know
okay when i grew up you guys are
probably don't remember this this woman
sued mcdonald's for because
she spilled her coffee i remember on
herself and she won like
five million dollars or something yeah
whatever because it burned her or
whatever
right hello
i'm uh i'm [ __ ] real i'm doing a
podcast right now
on concrete
all right
all right let me give you a call back
all right bye
i feel like he calls you every time
we're doing a podcast does he did he
last time yeah i think so
um so so the woman in mcdonald's just
this is the
like this is like the reason i feel like
this is like the woman in mcdonald's
everybody went nuts the media went nuts
they were like
this is ridiculous they're giving her
all this money
and they made a snap judgment that was
the that was the
the sound bite was she drove through the
dro the drive-through
asked for coffee she spilled it on
herself she sued and got five million
dollars now i don't know if it was three
and a half i don't know so i'm just
saying five
you know and boom isn't that so
ridiculous like how much does she get
three 1993 80 year old woman gets three
million dollars
because she suffered punitive damages
for the burns
right so here's the thing it was
dangerously it was not
just hot but dangerously hot well here's
the thing
so you you hear that and that's the
media right and you're like oh okay
you're like that is ridiculous
come on man you spilled the coffee
what's the problem right then you go
okay you know how could a jury find that
well because the jury found that
because the jury got all the facts you
didn't you don't get that off the news
you don't know what happened
what really happened is mcdonald's over
the last 10 years had been telling
mcdonald's
you're boiling your coffee and it's it
will cause you know whatever third
fourth fifth degree burns
you know people are complaining it's too
hot
and mcdonald's is saying you know we
don't care
people like it hot is it right so here's
what happens is it
hot it's so hot that the it's so hot it
[ __ ]
it's so hot that the ship that your your
cups and everything actually melt
right so the tops are popping off so
some woman they barely put on the top
they hand it to her
it drops in her lap and she has to have
skin grafts to do reconstructive surgery
on her vagina
oh [ __ ] an 80 year old vagina and they'd
be
yeah which is already gonna be hard
right to deal with what's the point
no one's looking down there anyways let
it [ __ ] leave the burn
scars so anyway it's better for the
settlement if you get the surgery i just
gotta get started
with that surgery yeah so now you know
that mcdonald's has known this is a
problem they've been told over and over
again they've completely
they've completely disregarded it this
woman gets burned
now what do you do you know now does
does she deserve to win and a good chunk
of money
hell yeah yeah yeah and the punitive
damages is it's not necessarily hey this
is your pain and suffering well what
we're saying is
what does that sound like bro god damn
it's my phone but
you guys [ __ ] ignorant what is that
sound that's like some old [ __ ]
computer
yeah you know
is that how they communicated with you
in prison so sign language that was so
that was so i'm saying now you look at
it and you go hey if you had to have
reconstructive surgery on your dick
because mcdonald's knew the coffee was
too hot and that it was melting the lids
they were negligent right they were
neglect now do you think you deserve
anything and then it's like oh yeah
yeah yeah okay now i see so you know
from the media he was found dead
i don't know but here's what i what
here's what really freaked me out so i'm
on the internet and everything
i'm watching all these videos about him
saying look if
i end up dead like they find my body
he actually tattoos the whacked yeah and
he's like i was whacked i was killed it
wasn't suicide i'm not suicidal i'm
doing fine i've got friends here i'm
good
so then he ends up getting killed and
everything on the me
on the internet where people are just
being able to report it
they're saying look this is insane this
is crazy but when
i watched abc news it was
so benign it was like mcafee what a life
he lived
he was very controversial he was
implicated in a murder in like aruba or
something i forget where it was belize
um he was implicated in murder he evaded
taxes
he was he was found he was indicted for
tax evasion he was looking he was
possibly going to spend the next 30
years in prison for tax evasion
he was caught in spain and they were
going to extradite him
and this is what he tweeted just before
you know he was his body was found and
the tweet was like
i have no more bitcoin i have no more
money
um i am something like you know i love
my family i am at peace
his body was found a week later you know
hours after
they really painted the picture and i'm
thinking to myself
are you serious did you guys just read
like the is that the us
press release you just read i mean if
you
even looked on if you'd even looked on
on
youtube or anything else and looked at
all this other you're not even going to
mention
that he said he wasn't suicidal he would
never kill himself you're not even going
to mention that right
they don't they completely went with
like the the party line right but we all
know all that corporate corporatized
media abc nbc fox we all know that's
owned by the government they're all
embedded with the government
so they're not going to go against the
government it's not normally obvious
like that
like it's not that like it was so like
you're you're literally
it was it was insane but everything it's
that's the complete opposite on the
internet though
everybody on the [ __ ] internet is
saying oh my god it's another epstein
the guy obviously didn't kill himself if
you could if you have a brain you've no
you could look up his twitter account
you can see all his tweets see his
tattoo see all that [ __ ] everyone
was saying that like there's no way this
guy actually killed himself
right i don't even know how here's the
problem here's what my problem is
i don't know even know how you'd kill
yourself in a cell like that
it's like like it it's it's but he
wasn't really in a cell was he he was
like he was
live streaming on the internet every day
he was he was
tweeting and and doing well he was silly
he was doing
podcasts not from yeah bro he had access
to like a podcast studio
there was a podcast he did like a month
before that
i think there there's video of him he's
on twitter every [ __ ] five minutes
yeah i mean i'm not sure how the like to
me i think it's very possible that he
obviously had access to some kind of
computer and he's tweeting or maybe a
phone i don't know
look spanish prisons are not
at the level he was at they're not
they're these are not harsh places
you know what i mean these are not harsh
prisons right
and they always make it sound like he's
going to do 30 years you know he's 75
years old he's going to do 30 years in
prison
wait a minute the history is going gonna
he's probably gonna do
three or four years maybe five years in
prison no if he goes to the u.s
and he's gonna be going i think he's
extra out of the u.s he's doing third
easily
tax evasion they'll be [ __ ] crucified
nearly to the cross bro
you do a couple of years right yeah
absolutely you do for that much
you'll do a few years he's just i mean
this isn't just tax evasion this guy
said straight up
[ __ ] you i'm not paying taxes i
understand but here's the difference
they'll say let's say they say 20
million dollars in tax evasion do you
understand they're saying you didn't pay
taxes on 20 million
okay so what do i owe you six
okay well if we'll make a deal i'll pay
you the six i'll do five years in prison
i'm out in three because i can take the
drug program
i'm probably two and a half or probably
in a halfway house i do two and a half
years
they're going to include the time that
he spent while incarcerated
already while he was incarcerated in um
in spain by the time you get here you're
looking at a year and a half to two
years
and you're out and i pay the six million
so he's not going do anything look they
said i was facing 154 years i was
never facing 100 yeah if i went to trial
and they
stacked it right to the map is it
impossible i mean yeah
see if you can pull up any sort of like
recent tax evasion case
like uh federal tax evasion prison
sentence because i've never been in
prison and met people
[Laughter]
so